nos piden ordenar las expresiones de
menor a mayor esto es de los ejercicios
de khan academy si lo estuviéramos
haciendo en el sitio de khan academy
podríamos arrastrar estas expresiones
para ordenar las de menor a mayor la
menor a la izquierda y la mayor a la
derecha aquí no puedo arrastrarlas
porque esto es solo una imagen así que
voy a evaluar cada una de estas
expresiones y las voy a reescribir de
menor a mayor
voy a empezar con dos a la tercera
potencia menos dos a la potencia uno
cuál es el resultado de esto dos a la
tercera potencia menos dos a la potencia
uno si se sienten seguros pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver el problema
ordenen las expresiones de menor a mayor
bueno dos a la tercera potencia es igual
a dos por dos por dos y luego dos a la
potencia uno es igual a dos dos por dos
es igual a cuatro por dos es igual a 8
menos dos esto es igual a seis así que
esta expresión de aquí podría ser
evaluada como 6 ahora qué pasa con esta
cuál es el resultado de esta tenemos 2
al cuadrado más 3 a la potencia 0 2 al
cuadrado es 2 por 2 y cualquier cosa
elevada a la potencia 0 es igual a 1
sería interesante pensar en cuanto es 0
elevado a la potencia cero pero eso es
tema de otro vídeo aquí tenemos 3
elevado a la potencia cero que
claramente es igual a 1 así que tenemos
2 x 2 más 1 esto es 4 más uno es igual a
5 este segundo cuadro es igual a 5 y
luego tenemos 3 al cuadrado bueno 3 al
cuadrado es igual a 3 x 3
que es igual a 9 así que vamos a ordenar
de menor a mayor
la menor de estas expresiones es 2 al
cuadrado más 3 a la potencia 0 este es
igual a 5 así que lo pondré a la
izquierda
luego tenemos este que es igual a 62 a
la tercera potencia menos 2 a la
potencia 1
y luego el que tiene el mayor valor es 3
al cuadrado
así que pondremos esta opción 3 al
cuadrado a la derecha y terminamos